hello everyone my name is bradley and
today i'm gonna answer quite an
important question
one that actually many of us are
probably wondering
that question is
how
long
will i live
now of course i'm going to answer this
question with the help of modern
technology which is why i've bought my
computer with me today
more importantly if you actually type
into google how long will i live
you get a number of different links to
a number of different sites now some of
these sites promise to determine how
long you have left to live with just a
couple of words and others demand that
you answer around 50 different questions
to get such an answer but which of these
can actually trust or are they all lying
well to answer this question i'm
actually going to test five different
life expectancy calculators online i'm
going to compare the results and also
figure out how they work but more
importantly if they work at all
so let's start with the simplest
calculator you can find it on the
website of the office for national
statistics
now this is primarily for the uk we've
got two variables here age and sex so
let's put 24
calculate
85 years not bad and we've got some nice
other statistics down here there's a one
in four chance i'll live to 95 one in 10
chance solid to 99 and also an 8.5
percent chance i'll live to a hundred so
this calculator predicts that i'm gonna
live another 59 years up to 85. it's not
bad but can we really trust it the
method that underpins this prediction
first appeared back in the roman empire
in the second century a.d domitius or
pianist became the head of the imperial
chancellery and one of the biggest
problems he faced here was the
collection of inheritance taxes now if
an heir received all of the property at
once then it was all pretty simple a
certain percentage was paid from the
value of the inheritance but in some
cases the inheritance couldn't be paid
immediately but rather in monthly
payments much like a pension to
calculate the amount of tax on such
inheritance it was necessary to know in
advance how many years the air would
live
so pianist ordered the collection of
statistics on previous payments and his
result was a simple table
if the air was younger than 20 then on
average this tax had to be paid for 30
years those who got their inheritance
between the ages of 20 and 24 lived on
average two years less and so on of
course this makes sense the older the
heir the less he or she had to live but
the important thing here is that the
relationship isn't exactly direct
that's why it's impossible to use a
simple indicator of average life
expectancy for the calculation infant
mortality for instance was incredibly
high therefore if you look at one
average value the romans lived for only
21 years on average but if you reach the
age of 15 you could expect to live
another 31 years
it turns out that if i'd been born in
ancient rome i would now be halfway
through my life
i would only have 28 years left to live
33 years less than the 2022 statistic
and by the way the author of the method
himself confirmed the validity of his
data we got a copy of this table from
the year 220. at the time all pianist
was about 50 years old
now according to the table he should
have lived for another nine years
in fact all pianist was murdered by his
political opponents at the age of 58.
what do you think coincidence or fate
but let's return back to the present day
the development of medicine has made it
possible to radically reduce child
mortality rates for example let's deduct
10 years
well so it goes up by
one year well let's deduct another 10
years let's say i'm four
goes up another year then according to
the ons he will live three years longer
than me and for a girl we'll sure reach
the age of 90. now this difference is
largely due to the fact that women
monitor their health more closely and
are less likely to get into car
accidents and also less likely to serve
in the army now these factors
significantly reduce the risk of a
premature death
so using a method based on a statistical
analysis of the country's population
looks pretty good but if you want to
compare the life expectancy in your
country with that of neighboring
countries then you'll need another tool
now here i recommend using data from the
united nations to compare this data i
use the website interface population dot
io and you can see there are a few more
variables for input here so we've got
the exact date of birth so we'll put
that in
so i was born on the 6th of february
1998.
let's choose the united kingdom for
instance i'm a male
click go
okay so when i click go and i scroll
down it seems that i have 63.1 years
left
of life in the united kingdom
they estimate that i'll live until the
age of 87.2
and i will die on the 6th of april 2085.
so this is already three years better
than the prediction from the ons
let's see what fate would have awaited
me if i had been born in some other
country for example china
so let's first of all put china
and we'll click go
despite the fact that the celestial
empire is known for the longevity of its
people the expected lifespan has been
reduced by a couple of years to 85. what
about someone like india well let's go
back and try india
and we'll click go
wow okay so that reduces massively so
that's gone from 87 to 79 years old so
it's clear that country has an impact
according to this site okay i wonder if
we can get that even lower let's try say
rwanda
let's click go
interesting okay so that's gone even
lower so now it's 75 much better than in
ancient rome of course but as much as
eight years younger than in my real
homeland perhaps this allows me to make
quite a reasonable assumption about the
quality of health care in certain
countries another person to actually
suggest analyzing death statistics was
my compatriot john graund now he owned a
haberdashery shop in 17th century london
and spent his spare time engaged in
scientific research in the 17th century
london was absolutely not a place you
would want to have lived the great
plague was ravaging the city for one and
to keep residents informed each week the
mayor's office published data on the
number of deceased citizens not this
data formed the basis of the first ever
statistical study of demographics grant
collected data on life over an 80-year
period and began to look for patterns as
an example he noticed that more boys are
born in london than girls grant also
calculated that more people die in the
city than are born which was quite
curious seeing as the population seemed
to grow year after year he eventually
explained this paradox with the fact
that migrants from all over the country
were actually flocking to the capital
and most importantly grant compiled the
first ever mortality table or as it's
now named grant's life table the essence
of his approach was extremely simple
grant discovered that out of 100 babies
born on average only 64 people lived to
the age of six
he then divided all of the agents groups
of 10 years and calculated the
probability of dying in each group
so only 40 out of 100 people lived to
the age of 16 and if i were in 1662 now
i would have already outlived 75
of londoners pretty scary numbers right
so in the end grant compiled the results
of his research into a 90 page book and
in it he describes demographic features
of different parts of the capital and
also its suburbs he also analyzed the
causes of child mortality and even made
predictions about the future changes in
the number of residents across the
country as a whole
in terms of his life grant managed to
survive the great fire of london and
died of jaundice just a few days before
his 54th birthday and according to the
table he managed to outlive about 90
percent of london residents it's pretty
good right
just a couple of years later the idea of
the life table was actually used for
commercial purposes for the very first
time to calculate the cost of life
insurance now the credit for this idea
belongs to jan dewitt in those years he
held the position of the grand
pensionary of the netherlands that is he
dealt with foreign policy issues led
parliamentary meetings and also managed
finances it's a bit like the prime
minister in today's terms
now unfortunately janderwicz is no not
for his life but rather for his death
together with his brother he was beaten
to death by a drunken crowd the
participants of the brutal massacre
began to cut off body parts
and well fry and eat them
the brothers fingers were cut off and
also sold as souvenirs and the mutilated
remains were hung in a crowded square in
the hague at the time of his death
jandewick was only 46 years old clearly
dutch prime ministers in the 17th
century were held responsible for their
actions
literally by their heads however it's
not only political opponents who are
able to greatly reduce one's lifespan
sometimes we
are our own worst enemies
let's take a look at this next model
now this calculator was created by
scientists from the university of
pennsylvania unlike previous models
they're already a dozen parameters at
play
in addition to gender and age here you
need to specify information about your
marital status your education your
income level and also frequency of
physical exercise
so let's go ahead with it i'm male i'm
white
24 years old
i'm about 165
pounds
uh i'm just under five ten you can't put
five nine and a half so let's put five
ten
um i'm a college graduate yes i am
married
currently working
uh
i earn over 80 000 a year
um fitness i i like the gym to be honest
so i i probably go
three to four times a week um and
because of that i think that i have very
good health let's say that
and i don't have diabetes
now alcohol and smoking
to begin with i'm going to answer
truthfully that i don't smoke or drink
alcoholic beverages mum i hope you're
watching this video
interesting so this is the first
calculator i've seen that actually takes
into account how much you drink and how
much you smoke so let's play around with
this a bit
now
in terms of myself i'm gonna be honest i
have about two to seven drinks per week
i like my whiskey
and i've never smoked which is true
so let's calculate my life expectancy
it's exciting
wow so it says that i'm going to live to
99 years old
that is incredible this is the highest
number we've seen for today conclusion
don't smoke and don't drink right
however i actually violated the first
rule of a combatant researcher here i
changed two parameters at once and
therefore it's too early to draw
conclusions
so let's say that i don't drink at all
zero alcohol but i smoke
let's say a pack a day right
now calculate
let's see how that changes the estimate
so it was 99 years old what is it going
to be now
83
but what happens if we don't smoke but
we drink as much as tommy shelby from
peaky blinders so let's say i've never
smoked but
i drink eight or more drinks a week okay
that's more than one drink a day
calculate
98
wow
so if i drink every single day with my
current lifestyle
i'll live to 98 years old i mean that
can't be right can it okay but an
interesting question here is what if
with my current lifestyle i were to
smoke a pack of cigarettes a day and i
were to drink
let's say eight or more
drinks a week so let's say still smoke
one pack a day
wow so i'll still live to 85 years old
if i smoke a pack of cigarettes a day
and i drink every day wait that's more
than if i didn't drink at all
so effectively the advice of blueprint
income is if you're smoking a pack of
cigarettes a day you can increase your
life expectancy
by drinking
i definitely like this model but there
are clearly a few issues with it i
suspect the problem lies in the very
concept of estimated life expectancy
this indicator isn't actually calculated
in the most intuitive of ways in the
previous examples we talked about the
processing of statistical data from past
periods for instance grant used
statistics from 80 years of research and
this is more than the life expectancy of
99.9 percent of his contemporaries and
by the time the study began almost all
of them were already dead
perhaps this gave satisfactory results
back in the 17th century but now the
healthcare system is changing much
faster and therefore estimated life
expectancy takes a different approach to
its calculations let's say that we want
to find out the life expectancy for
those who like me were born in 1998 now
those who study demographics assume that
in the future people will die in the
same proportion as they die this year
therefore they record how many newborns
one-year-olds and so on all died in 98.
if i want to find out the probability of
death at 90 well i'd have to check how
many 90-year-olds died in the year of my
birth
do you understand the issue here
medicine is continuously developing so
life expectancy is constantly increasing
look at these graphs do you see how the
age of death has shifted to the right
over the past 170 years
so the estimated life expectancy usually
gives a somewhat
understated value in different models
they try to bring it closer to real life
with the help of additional coefficients
but look why did small doses of alcohol
increase the estimated life expectancy
well i will assume that in this case
this indicator was calculated separately
for people who
do not drink alcohol and those who drink
up to seven standard doses per week in
1998 the alcohol-free diet had not yet
become fashionable if a person didn't
drink alcohol at all it was often
associated with health problems most
medications rule out even a small glass
of beer for instance and therefore i'd
venture a guess that within the
statistics of the end of the 20th
century the moderately drinking group
was initially somewhat healthier not to
mention that the occasional glass of
wine can do wonders for your stress
levels i'm not sure we should be saying
that on youtube but anyway it's curious
but i'm not the first to encounter this
kind of unusual data if you're
interested in this topic type french
paradox into your search bar people have
been arguing about it since 1986
so let's test out this theory on another
site
now this resource is based on a model
proposed by scientists of the university
of minnesota to get a final result
you'll have to answer 50 questions but
for my experiment i'm just going to use
an interesting feature of the site look
at this scale at the top of the screen
when i answer questions related to
nutrition and bad habits the number of
days in my life increases or decreases
this is a great way to check how alcohol
affects the calculation so the answer of
zero doses added 80 days to my life but
four doses of alcohol a week shortened
my life by 40 days it seems that the
guys from minnesota have a completely
different attitude to
alcohol well i completed the entire test
and i was pretty pleased with the result
moreover the creators promised to
increase it for another seven years if i
follow their recommendations not a bad
advertising move can anyone resist
clicking on such a button however i'm
going to add this value to our timeline
to be honest i like the idea of adding
days for correct answers there's
something of the good old rpg here but
just how justified are these figures how
do scientists know how many days red
meat is adding or say salty snacks are
deducting well this is the data that
researchers receive within the framework
of evidence-based medicine for many
centuries doctors treated diseases based
on their own experiences they learned
maybe something from mentors and maybe a
bit from medical pamphlets it's
therefore no surprise that in the middle
ages healers and surgeons more often
mutilated than treated people
but in the middle of the 17th century a
modest ship surgeon made a revolution
on a long voyage on the ship of james
lind scurvy began to rear its ugly head
the bodies of the sailors were covered
with rashes and ulcers their gums began
to bleed and eventually their teeth
began to fall out the situation was
desperate and lind decided on a bold
experiment he divided the six sailors
into six groups and began to treat them
with well whatever was at hand one group
received cider the other washed down the
food with sea water the third saw drops
of viterol and the fourth vinegar and
the most effective remedy turned out to
be fresh fruit as we already know scurvy
is caused by lack of vitamin c and in
those days it was easiest to get vitamin
c from citrus fruits right which is why
sailors were often called limeys because
they were sucking on limes the whole
time after this revelation so after
returning from this voyage linde shared
his results by writing a treatise on
scurvy
so there was what we would now call a
controlled clinical trial
lind lived for 77 long years but never
received proper recognition for his work
but now three centuries later clinical
research forms the foundation of all
medicine the effectiveness of any new
medicine or vaccine must be confirmed
with the help of such studies and this
is why also the method of comparative
tests has been adopted by nutritionists
that's where specific figures tend to
come into play how many beans nuts or
vegetables can basically change your
life expectancy but is everything really
this simple unfortunately it's quite the
opposite our body is an incredibly
complex thing by interfering with its
inner workings with say medicines we're
upsetting the natural balance side
effects add up over time and multiply if
we use several different drugs
research is becoming more and more
complicated and we're trying to take
into account more and more new factors
data volumes are also rapidly increasing
and models are becoming increasingly
more complex
[Music]
take a look at the website of dr thomas
pearls what do you think
doesn't it look like a relic from the
90s well even if it is this is the most
thoughtful and multi-factorial model of
the life expectancy calculator there are
questions about hereditary diseases
lifestyle food preferences some of them
we actually saw in the previous
calculators but many are unique for
example the question of whether i fasten
my seat belt when i'm driving it's quite
an important question when you think
about it
right okay let's try and go through this
quickly so
married
um
would you have in person contact with
family members or friends uh yeah i
think so yeah
current stress level medium um
doing alright
sleep habits i have very good sleep
habits
i have a postgraduate qualification
are you optimistic about your aging or
pessimistic i think i'm getting better
with age i think i'm getting more sexy
with age so
i don't know uh okay air quality i think
it's average i live in a city um [ __ ]
born i i i don't use my seat belt in the
car it's very bad
uh how many cups of caffeine coffee you
drink per day one to two cups cups of
tea three to five do you smoke
no
i don't chew any tobacco i don't smoke
[Music]
often tick aspirin i never take aspirin
i never wear
sunscreen i live in london
who does who does
uh do you ever engage in risky sexual
unprotected behavior
is this something i should be telling
the audience what
i'm married i am married and this is a
strange question of course i do not
never
what does risky mean though
[Music]
do you body build or strength train uh
that your bmi is high because of muscle
that's an interesting question it's a
really really interesting question um
i think i strength train so maybe but
i'm not that heavy so
[Music]
do you have a bowel movement at least
once every two days this will not this
cannot be in the video
oh my god at least once every two days
yes i do i think i'm fairly normal do
you regularly swim skin
no i don't
[Music]
okay your calculated life expectancy is
87
not bad not the highest that we've seen
but i think 87 is still pretty good lots
of different questions as well i like
that i'm pretty happy 87. let's go
okay so let's summarize the results of
this experiment firstly i was surprised
by such a small spread of predictions
there's only a six year difference
between the minimum and maximum values
in terms of predicting the events of 60
years down the line this really isn't
much of a gap and it also seems that
additional factors on average tend to
have less effect on the life of a
particular person if i drink too much
get behind the wheel and demolish a red
phone booth right it will greatly affect
my life expectancy but it will have
little effect on
future calculations
and finally the big question is can we
trust all of these calculators and
applications or services
i want to say yes but no we can't in
fact while these are good tools for
visualizing the statistical data they're
not able to predict the life expectancy
of an individual now in order for such a
forecast to differ from say
well
fortune telling we need to combine
several new technologies together now
information about the individual
characteristics of bubbly's workings can
actually be collected using new models
of smartphones let's say fitness
bracelets and smart watches
until very recently they were only able
to measure your pulse and now they're
able to identify things like heart
problems by changing their gait and
approximately estimate the oxygen level
in the blood
i'm sure there are many new features
waiting for us in the future that we
don't even know about yet the second
direction is big data processing
clinical studies are rapidly
accumulating and it's getting
increasingly difficult to combine them
into meta analyses we need new methods
information processing including those
that allow us to work with confidential
data without the threat of their
disclosure or data leaks right and
finally data from portable devices will
also be processed in
an unusual way
soon there will be extensive use of
neural networks so far they're just
learning how to help oncologists and
also trying to process individual
medical histories with the growth of
computing power well they'll come to our
smartphones as well and this has already
happened with siri so in a couple of
years
my iphone might actually speak with the
voice of dr house it's basic truth of
the human condition
that everybody lies and this will make
it possible to make a leap from the
average life expectancy data to the
calculation of personalized life
expectancy right a real bespoke process
and in any case i'm absolutely sure that
every year we're going to be living
longer and longer thanks to better diets
and medical innovations etc well anyway
my name is bradley peake and thank you
for joining me on another jungle
adventure lastly i've got a question
to subscribe
or not to subscribe
see in the next video
[Music]
you